hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on blockchain
developer full course
in this video we will explore all the
important features and concepts
revolving around blockchain starting
with what is blockchain who is
blockchain developer how can one become
a blockchain developer what are the
applications of blockchain and why does
it matter
then we will understand the complete
mechanism and architecture of blockchain
following that we will explore some of
the most important concepts of
blockchain like what are hyperledgers
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin ethereum
dogecoin and towards the end we will
have a look at the comparison between
them we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help every
individual clear an interview with full
confidence
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your blockchain career
related queries would have been answered
for this training with me i have
experienced blockchain specialist rahul
and sora together we will take you
through the various important keynotes
of blockchain so let's start with an
exciting video on blockchain developer
full course before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon and never miss an update
from simply learn
ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends jack ted
sam and phil meet up for dinner after
they're done jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when phil sends his share to jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then ted
and sam send their respective shares to
jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transaction cites
some issues at the bank that's when jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like litecoin ethereum
c cash and so on one reigns supreme
bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have bill ted and
sam send jack two bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume phil ted and sam
have three bitcoins in reserve while
jack has five first phil sends two
bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block this record also
holds the number of bitcoins each of the
friends own so after phil's transaction
jack has seven bitcoins while phil has
one following this sam and ted send two
bitcoins to jack a new block is created
for each of these transactions these
blocks hold the transaction details as
well as how many bitcoins sam ted and
jack have in reserve these blocks are
linked to each other as each of them
takes reference from the previous one
for the number of bitcoins each brand
owns this chain of records or blocks is
called a ledger and this ledger is
shared among all the friends which acts
as a public distributed ledger this
forms the basis of blockchain so what
happens when phil has only one bitcoin
left and he tries to send two more
bitcoins to jack the transaction will
not go through this is because all his
friends have copies of the ledger and
it's clear that phil has only one
bitcoin left his friends will flag this
transaction as invalid a hacker will not
be able to alter the data in the
blockchain because each user has a copy
of the ledger the data within the blocks
are encrypted by complex algorithms all
of this is made possible with the help
of blockchain technology blockchain can
be described as a collection of records
linked with each other strongly
resistant to alteration and protected
using cryptography now let's have a
closer look at the bitcoin transaction
between jack and phil and find out how
it works every user in the bitcoin
network has two keys a public key and a
private key the public key is an address
that everyone in the network knows of
like an email address of a user the
private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first bill passes the
number of bitcoins he wants to send to
jack along with his and jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are
encrypted using encryption algorithms
and using phil's unique private key this
is done to digitally sign the
transaction
and to indicate that the transactions
came from phil this output is now
transmitted across the world using
jack's public key with this the message
or transaction can be decrypted only by
jack's private key which only jack has
knowledge of different cryptocurrencies
use different hashing algorithms while
bitcoin uses the sha-256 algorithm
ethereum which is also a famous
cryptocurrency uses one known as ethash
this transaction and several other
similar ones are taking place all around
the world these transactions are
validated and then added block by block
the people who validate these blocks are
called miners for a block to be
validated and added to a blockchain
miners need to solve a complex
mathematical problem the miner who
solves this first adds the block to the
blockchain and is rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining
with this phil and jack's wallets are
updated just like every person in the
network who has completed a transaction
now that you know about blockchain and
its important concepts time for a small
quiz what is the concept of blockchain
that ensures data cannot be altered by
any of the users within the network a
public distributed ledger b
proof of work
c proof of stake d
hash encryption let us know what you
think is the right answer in the
comments below let's have a look at how
walmart uses blockchain to provide its
customers with better service walmart
was facing problems in delivering
quality products to its customers they
were facing a high return rate and large
amounts of refunds due to their products
bad quality they were unable to
determine the point of failure in the
supply chain which started from farm to
storage to transportation to processing
all the way to the customer then walmart
adopted blockchain technology with
blockchain the quality of the goods at
each step was permanently inscribed
within a block for example when a
customer flags a product as damaged it
can be correctly identified where the
product got damaged in the entire supply
chain thus helping walmart to identify
the problem areas and fixing them and
this is just one of several ways
blockchain is used in real life
application ray is a tech savvy guy and
loves to spend most of his time
exploring the web on his laptop
one fine day he was going through an
article on futuristic gadgets and
suddenly he noticed an ad for the ps5
popping right beside the article he
found it a little strange as he recalled
searching for that just a few hours ago
later that day he came across some
suggestive ads popping up related to
buying future leading gadgets
and that is when he freaked out thinking
how can it be possible that what he was
searching for just a few hours or days
ago on the internet is now suggesting
ads related similar to them
so he thought of going to his elder
brother aaron who is a software engineer
in an mnc
upon understanding the situation
he explained to ray that all of this is
happening because we are in an era of
web 2.0
it all started in 1994 when web 1.0 was
introduced to the internet
basically web 1.0 was all read only
content that was not interactable and
was similar to a huge wikipedia page
but after a few years in 2004 web 2.0
came into the picture
web 2.0 made the internet much more
interactive because of developments in
web technologies such as javascript
html5 css3 and others which allowed
companies to create interactive web
platforms like youtube facebook
wikipedia and many more
he further added that when we seek out
information or data of any kind from any
web platforms present on the internet
simultaneously unknowingly we also
provide them with information related to
our choices and interests
which are stored in cookies which later
they sell to various companies who make
use of this data to advertise exactly
what you are looking for
and this is how ray was able to see ads
of his concerned interests
ray was fascinated by how the internet
has evolved and how it works amazingly
but at the same time he was concerned
about the lack of privacy offered by it
ray out of his concern asked aaron is
there any way that one can get rid of
the loopholes of the current web 2.0
when aaron answered yes there are a lot
of ways to do that using tor browser
incognito mode etc
but these are not permanent solutions
and there can be fluctuations in their
reliability but this scenario can be
changed not just for you but for
everyone using the internet with the
help of web 3.0
ray was curious about it and asked what
is web 3.0
aaron explained that web 3.0 is the next
step in the evolution of the internet
allowing it to process data with near
human intelligence through the use of
artificial intelligence and blockchain
technologies
that run innovative programs to help
users by providing them with their
relevant choices
it's a significant step toward open
trusting and permissionless networks
aaron further added to fully comprehend
this we must first explore the four key
features of web 3.0
first is decentralization
blockchain will help to centralize data
storage while also establishing trust in
the virtual world
because web 3.0 allows information to be
retrieved based on its content it can be
kept in several locations simultaneously
making it decentralized this would
dismantle the vast databases currently
maintained by internet giants like
facebook now meta and google giving more
power over people second is trustful and
permissionless
web 3.0 will also be trustful and
permissionless which means that
participants will be able to interact
directly without the need for a trusted
intermediary or permission from a
governing body
due to this you can access any data
relevant to your choice without any
permission from any other node or third
party for example
if you are researching for some data you
don't need to accept its cookies or you
don't need to provide any sort of
details as there is a trustful bond
between you and the web
third is artificial intelligence and
machine learning
in web 3.0 through technology based on
semantic web ideas and natural language
processing
computers will be able to understand the
information in the same way that people
do
for example i love paris and i heart
paris may seem different in syntax
however their semantics are nearly
identical this will help the user to
achieve more relevant content to their
choices and will provide them ease with
internet browsing
fourth is connectivity and ubiquity
in web 3.0 the internet will be
accessible to everyone anywhere at any
time
because iot internet of things
technology will launch in several new
smart devices
these internet connected devices will no
longer be limited to pcs and smartphones
as they were in web 2.0 understanding
the shortcomings of web 2.0 corporates
like amazon apple and google are
transforming their existing services
into internet 3.0 apps that abide by
these four principles
siri and wolfram alpha are two
applications that use web 3.0 features
after learning about this ray was
relieved by the fact that web 3.0 is
going to bring so much of a difference
not just in his life but also to the
society as a whole
so here's a question for you
how is web 3.0 related to blockchain
a
it helps create smart contracts for web
pages on the internet
b
it helps web 3.0 storage data in the
blockchain
c
it offers a decentralized experience to
its users
d
all of the above
please take a minute to think about it
and leave your answers in the comments
section below
web 3.0 will offer a more personalized
and customized surfing experience
and a smarter and more human-like search
assistant and other decentralized
benefits
all of which are believed to contribute
to a more fair web
this will be accomplished by giving each
user control over their data
resulting in a richer overall experience
in a nutshell the internet will become
considerably more intertwined in our
daily lives when web 3.0 arrives let's
get started with who is a blockchain
developer
a blockchain developer is a person who
is responsible for developing and hence
enhancing blockchain related
applications famously known as dapps
smart contracts architecture and
protocols
for those who don't know what blockchain
is
blockchain is a system of recording
details of transactions in a block
taking place in the blockchain network
that makes it difficult or impossible to
change or hack
which means they are immutable
a blockchain is essentially a digital
public ledger of transactions that is
copied and distributed across the entire
network of computer systems on the
blockchain
basically blockchain developers enable
secure digital transactions by creating
systems and applications to record and
store blockchain data and prevent
external changes or hacks
that brings us to what are the types of
blockchain developers
there are two types of blockchain
developers
core blockchain developers and
blockchain software developers
each type has its specific type of role
let's go through them in more detail
the core blockchain developers designed
the protocols required to run a
blockchain solution successfully which
means they are majorly responsible for
the architecture development of
blockchain
they are also responsible for designing
consensus protocols and making
high-level decisions
blockchain software developers
develop and implement the blockchain
using the designs and solutions created
by the core blockchain developers
they are majorly responsible for
designing and implementing smart
contracts and developing decentralized
applications or dapps
now let's understand what are the
technical skills required to become a
blockchain developer
to become a blockchain developer you
need to have a specific set of technical
skills let's take a look at them
understanding blockchain architecture
for starters you should have a complete
understanding of blockchain technology
its architecture how it works and its
critical concepts like hash functions
distributed ledger technology and
consensus protocols
next data structure and coding
data structures and coding are
considered the most basic and essential
skills required to be a fine developer
it is a must-have skill to become a
blockchain developer as it enhances your
ability to play and configure blockchain
according to your requirements
development of smart contracts
smart contracts is the most vital part
of blockchain technology the programming
language solidity is used to create
smart contracts
ethereum is the best example for smart
contracts it helps you set up the
business and develop and deploy dapps
using smart contracts
and at last basic knowledge of
cryptography
blockchain secures its data by using
highly effective cryptography algorithms
cryptography helps you implement dabs
and other blockchain services
now we have covered the technical skills
required to become a blockchain
developer let's explore the roles and
responsibilities of a blockchain
developer
both core blockchain developer and
blockchain software developer have
different roles and responsibilities
first we will discuss the roles and
responsibilities of code blockchain
developer
core blockchain developer understand and
implement the features and
functionalities of blockchain
they design protocols and consensus
protocols for blockchain networks
they create solutions for providing
security to the data stored in the
blockchain network
and then make sure that the blockchain
network functions smoothly and securely
now blockchain software developer design
and implement smart contracts
they develop and deploy decentralized
application or dabs as per the
requirements
also they look after the integration
with other applications and services
now let's dive down and explore the
companies hiring blockchain developers
there is a massive demand for blockchain
developers and if you know your skills
well you will surely get a good start
with your career as blockchain developer
joining a programmers community and
working on real projects will help you
learn grow and upskill yourself
according to 2021 science of a software
development company ripple labs and
corporation an american technology
company that deals with the ripple
payment
leeway herds a software development
company for startup at enterprises
chrome away a blockchain technology
company
open ledger a decentralized financial
platform used to convert bitcoins to
smart coins
an intellect soft a company specialized
in providing software products and
integrated solutions are a few top
companies who hired blockchain
developers to work on blockchain
technology
now that we know about the demand of
blockchain developers worldwide let's
figure out the average salary of a
blockchain developer in both the usa and
india
in the usa the average salary of
blockchain developer is over 157 000
dollars per year
and in india it ranges from 5 lakh
rupees 30 lakh rupees per year
so this is all about who is a blockchain
developer
hi guys i'm rahul from simply learn and
today i'm going to tell you how you can
become a blockchain developer now before
we begin let's see the current situation
of the market 84 percent of companies
are now dabbling into blockchain
blockchain is the fastest growing skill
in the u.s freelance job market apple st
wozniak is getting involved with
blockchain projects and jpmorgan cio
believes that blockchain will replace
existing technology as we can see with
the amount of focus organizations are
putting on blockchain and what tech
influencers around the world have to say
about it we can see clearly that they
really believe that blockchain can have
a tremendous positive impact on our
lives and the market as a whole so it's
no surprise that blockchain has
worldwide acclaim now it's created a
huge number of job opportunities across
the world and one such job is that of a
blockchain developer so here's what
we're going to learn today who is a
blockchain developer what are the types
of blockchain developers the steps you
have to follow to become a blockchain
developer the obstacles you might face
while learning blockchain the salaries
offered to blockchain developers and how
companies are using blockchain right now
so who is a blockchain developer a
blockchain developer is someone who
designs implements and supports a
blockchain network so in a way they are
responsible for setting up the
blockchain network and then ensuring
that it works properly they create and
optimize blockchain protocols for
example is the network a public network
they create such protocols and then
optimize it based on that usage or
requirement they develop distributed
applications and smart contracts on the
blockchain network now let's talk about
the different types of blockchain
developers so they fall under two major
categories core blockchain developers
and blockchain software developers a
core blockchain developer works on the
core features and the architecture of
the blockchain network basically they're
in charge of the entire blockchain
network they manage the architecture of
the network supervise the blockchain
network they work on consensus
algorithms for example there's the
proof-of-work algorithm in bitcoin and
set up blockchain protocols a core
blockchain developer works very much
like a core web developer now the main
thing is that they both work on course
concepts now just like blockchain
developers work on protocols you have
web developers working on protocols like
http or tcpip and so on now let's talk
about a blockchain software developer
now they work on blockchain to create
applications now they create smart
contracts develop distributed
applications and work on the front and
back end application development
blockchain software developers are also
very similar to web application
developers both of them create
applications on a network that's already
set up by core developers so how do you
become a blockchain developer so before
you start off on your path to becoming a
blockchain developer there are some
things that you really have to know now
we're going to talk about the
prerequisites first up you have
programming languages now it is
absolutely necessary that you be
well-versed in programming languages
before you can get on to blockchain
development most blockchains are created
in languages like java c plus javascript
go python c sharp and so on so let me
emphasize how important it is that you
know programming languages now for core
blockchain development any of these
aforementioned languages will do the job
for you however in case you have to
create distributed applications and
smart contracts on ethereum it is
mandatory that you learn the programming
language solidity then you need to
understand the fundamentals of
object-oriented programming now the
concepts of object-oriented programming
which anyone who codes will know is the
wrapping up of data and functions into a
single unit this is exactly what
blockchains function on for example you
have the ethereum block here it has two
components data and function the user
details act as the data now this data
includes the person who's sending the
transaction or how much money they're
planning to transfer then you have the
function which is the command to send
and receive payments then you need to
learn about flat and relational
databases now blockchain was created on
the basis of these two types of
databases a flat database stores data in
a single table structure and a
relational database uses a number of
tables and can cross reference records
across tables so it is necessary that
you understand how these two databases
work to completely understand how
blockchain was created from their
concepts then you need to learn what
data structures are you need to
understand the working of data
structures like stack linked list queue
and so on this is because blockchain by
itself is a backlinked list each block
in a blockchain references the previous
block now this is done by a field in the
blocks header known as the previous hash
that holds the hash value of the
preceding block knowledge about web
application development by being well
versed in web app development you're
opening yourself to a wide range of
opportunities to create web and mobile
applications using blockchain technology
because regardless of whether the
application works on blockchain
technology the front end can be created
only with web application development
then you need to know about networking
blockchains work on the internet so you
need to understand the many concepts
regarding networks for example how
systems are able to communicate with
each other how the network works and so
much more now after you're done with all
of this you're ready to start your
journey to become a blockchain developer
the first step is to understand the
concepts of blockchain now satoshi
nakamoto's whitepaper bitcoin appear to
peer electronic cash system gives a
detailed account on how bitcoin works
and introduces us to the concept of
blockchain so if you want to learn
firsthand how blockchain works from the
creator of bitcoin himself i would
suggest you go to satoshi nakamoto's
paper next you need to learn important
terms related to blockchain for example
what is a minor what is a block what is
a public distributed ledger hash
encryption proof of work mining and so
much more then you can learn how systems
other than bitcoin like ethereum
hyperledger hashgraph and so on use
blockchain to work with their technology
the second step involves understanding
the economics behind cryptocurrencies in
blockchain blockchain technologies work
on crypto economics which is nothing but
the combination of two words
cryptography and economics cryptography
in blockchain involves hashing digital
signatures and proof of work hashing is
involved in maintaining the privacy of a
user within the network this is made
possible with the help of cryptographic
algorithms for example in bitcoin we
have the sha-256 algorithm and et hash
in ethereum digital signatures help
validate a particular user within the
network this is made possible with the
combination of the user's public and
private keys proof of work involves
miners around the world trying to solve
a complex mathematical puzzle to be able
to add a block to the blockchain on the
economic side you need to understand how
miners are incentivized the users who
add and take part in the blockchain are
given cryptocurrencies now people who
take decisions also have the right to
charge a fee for their service for
example if a person has a block and he
has to decide what transactions he's
going to add to that block he has the
right to charge you some amount of money
if you want your transaction to be added
to his block good users of the network
are rewarded with monetary compensation
or the ability to take decisions bad
users of the network have to pay a fine
or have their rights to take decisions
stripped away step three is to
understand how cryptocurrencies work
with cryptocurrencies there's a whole
number of steps before a process is
complete you need to understand how each
and every step works for example first
how a sender begins the transaction to
send money to the receiver how the
message is encrypted and transmitted
across the network how miners are able
to verify that transaction how the block
is added to the blockchain how money is
deducted from each of the participants
wallets you need to understand the
relationship between each and every step
of the process and how they interact
with each other step 4 getting some
hands-on experience now after you're
done with all the steps that i mentioned
before this one's the hardest practical
application so even if you know all the
theory if you don't have any practical
experience it won't have a very large
impact so you need to start coding and
creating your own smart contracts you
need to create your own distributed
applications on the ethereum platform
also let me remind you for you to be
able to create smart contracts or
distributed applications you need to
have learned the programming language
solidity and finally you can invest in
bitcoins or other cryptocurrencies so
that you can have an understanding of
how they actually work now it's very
important that you also keep yourself
updated regarding cryptocurrencies and
blockchains and bitcoins by reading up
on blogs and forums you can take part in
discord chat rooms you can use the
telegram application which has a very
active community on cryptocurrencies and
blockchain you can involve yourself in
subreddits like our slash blockchain r
slash bitcoin and other related
subreddits you can get on coin market
cap that talks about market
capitalizations of several
cryptocurrencies coin market cal and so
much more there's an abundance of
resources on the internet that you can
take advantage of now let's talk about
the obstacles that you might face while
learning blockchain now you've noticed
that blockchain isn't very easy there's
a lot of content to cover now to make
matters worse you could also face some
of these problems first of them a